[Música]
estou esta expressão é o primeiro
empréstimo em uma amiga minha brasil era
é é uma e todas aquelas coisas vega nem
assim e dodô cross fit e por norma ela
costuma fazer uma coisa que é tem tido a
sua mãe na hora da estréia
é hora de apostar essencialmente no
momento em que ela decidiu cobrar com
todos os protocolos normais dela dizer
vega eles não comer carboidratos mais e
que ela costuma fazer é comer tudo o que
aparece à frente deixaram seguir o
instinto dela e essa franquia sobre
qualquer forma que hoje sobre nós sermos
um pouco os nossos instintos e deixarmos
que as nossas redes sociais não toma em
conta as nossas vidas
e esse tema é da minha toca hoje
essencialmente ao trabalho com ficção
como ano terá percebido pela minha
apresentação foi um carro mas eu escrevi
uma telenovela já escrevi um filme
atualmente escreve - porque faz outras
coisas é tomar mais tempo em que dão
mais dinheiro é ficção pra mim eu sempre
foi matéria daquilo com que eu trabalhar
desde que seja facultada essencialmente
eu posso descrevê lo como um produto da
nossa imaginação momento uma mentira
pode ser considerada a infecção no
sentido em que nós temos a imaginar algo
estamos a tentar contar uma história
falsa professor é algumas pessoas e foi
sobre sobre ficção que fui tentando
trabalhar nos últimos tempos
diria que é de que o ficção é hoje em
dia está a tomar conta do jogo mas errou
mas não é não entrar em algum momento
essa mesma posição específica entre duas
pessoas
há uns meses eu eu ficar solteiro é eu
já não estou portanto eu espero voltou a
abrir no é esse plano já está resolvido
[Música]
é irônico
assim se inscrever numa rede social do
encontro sempre provoca risos eu sair
vai ficar mais risos convencer e o que
acontece
se inscrever nesta rede vai passar a
publicidade que chama tinga e de tentar
conhecer novas pessoas e isso é tudo
online porque é uma pessoa que não gosta
de conhecer pessoas técnicas e tudo mais
não só tem muito pouco tempo tenta aliar
essas duas vertentes e foi quarto na nas
redes sociais dos encontros sobretudo
entender e muito frio no primeiro um
filme incrível acordo minhas melhores
fotos elas têm mais likes no facebook
as fotos que uma biografia muito cuidada
dizia que era uma pessoa que estava no
livros e vinho como devem calcular é
muito interessante para a maior parte
das mulheres não é o que acontece é que
inicia se lançar à minha candidatura
online para o mundo das mulheres está na
10 metros neste dia
no segundo dia mais pessoas não tinham
já fui dando mais chances a mais pessoas
e 100 metros no terceiro dia se lutava
vou usar a minha biografia
vamos ver as minhas fotos todas para
tentar ter alguma coisa mais sedutor
ainda obviamente não funcionou e já
aconteceu na história vai para a área e
passa uma semana eu tenho 10 metros e
bater o recorde mundial a única pessoa
que está no tinga e não tem um único
metro e como não sou muito interessante
vou tentar perceber porque é que isso
aconteceu em conclusão
hoje em dia está o problema é que as
pessoas têm infecção aparentemente por
porque não consigo decifrar a ficção
está em 3d começa em porque não tenha
sucesso nessa nas redes sociais encontro
essencialmente eu percebi que hoje em
dia existe uma tendência crescente para
é o marília já falar sobre esse conceito
mais à frente
as redes sociais enquanto está em todas
elas é tendência
as pessoas estão cada vez mais
apaixonados por pessoas humildes elas
próprias a vez de procurarem segmentar
o seu o senhor só compromisso amoroso
pouquinho pra quem não conhece muito bem
a aplicação é uma aplicação de encontros
que tem cerca de 50 milhões de
utilizadores diários em em 2014 essa
aplicação fazia cerca de 19 anos e sua
esposa os flaps é pra quem não pra cá
não compreendo por que não com essa
aplicação são essencialmente usar vídeos
para a esquerda para a direita ou para
cima essencialmente assim que está a ser
seguido nos romances nos dias 2 e 11 de
junho para a esquerda para a direita
a próxima é incrível o que aconteceu foi
que obviamente vistos os sites para vir
até nós os choques negativos e tenta
compreender os e vou tentar explicar por
que afinal sou uma pessoa muito
interessante e vou tentar pôr o problema
do lado da aplicação do meu justifica os
quais as pessoas usam tinta não sei se é
positivo para todos vocês ao i
mas acima de tudo são só isso querem
fazer sexo querem fazer querem fazer
novos amigos querem ter novas coleções
querem viajar querem autorização e
querem sobretudo entre terça são os
motivos que as pessoas apresentam a tv e
me perguntaram e acho que é sempre
interessante nós temos um creme à frente
uma pessoa perguntar por que o ser
humano rede social do encontro
essencialmente esse crime só espero que
as pessoas sejam feridas sejam sejam
brasileiras com deus e efetivamente elas
foram por pessoas quer fazer sexo e uma
parte das pessoas quer quer ter uma
relação
o que eu acho que um caso estranho são
as duas dizem que querem fazer amizade
no twitter mas aparentemente a manhã em
uma expressão muito grande de pessoas
que querem encontrar um amigo online e
se usar uma rede social que pretende
manter só o encontro preço de tudo isto
está um trecho em questão três níveis
psicológicos que influenciam muitas
pessoas nas redes sociais enquanto seu
narcisismo é a autoestima ea solidão
essencialmente são esses três fatores
que vão além da atuação de cada uma das
pessoas nessas redes sociais enquanto
amy teria como diz é que as redes
sociais têm um fundo
tchau e como é que testou o serviço para
o iraque pode parecer um pouco de preto
mas essencialmente eu tentei ficar manhã
em ferramentas da ficção que o conheço
em e tentar aplicá las à altura e isso
[Música]
acabou por bater certo na maior parte
dos casos
vou começar a falar sobre o personagem
todos nós conhecemos personagens do
mundo é ficção
os mais velhos os contratos da música no
coração para os intermédios tony soprano
dos seus planos para os mais jovens
criaram o twitch irão é um um laudo
alguns de vocês mas essencial muitas
personagens que estão a ser construídas
no twitter
hoje em dia somos nós próprios um
problema do casal
nós temos a capacidade de alterar as
nossas biografias como já disse é
manipular as nossas fotos de uma certa
maneira isso faz com que nós próprios
nos problemas da espécie de personagem
neste quadro estão várias
características que as pessoas costumam
mudar nossas próprias quando em fotos em
redes sociais enquanto convém ao i
altura errada papel sem atos não têm os
dedos adicionais branco só são mais
amarelos para menos no bolso mas samuel
mais brancos amarelos o não combinar
essencialmente que estava a acontecer é
que é que nós vamos formando um
arquétipo de pessoa que queremos será em
função da pessoa que queremos conhecer e
muitas vezes isso acaba por arredondar
empresário comanda a perceber mais tarde
sobretudo com duas coisas essencialmente
as pessoas procuram um validades mais
nas negociações com uma autoestima mais
baixa e são pessoas pane eo mesmo
encontrar uma relação profunda nas redes
sociais encontra isto é as pessoas com
mais com um nível maior de autoconfiança
no momento são mais os ninhos por
incrível que possa parecer as pessoas
que não procuram é um cozimento mais
longos todos procuram só amizade
são pessoas que normalmente não mentem
tanto né nas redes sociais
nós acabamos por formar aqui uma espécie
de personagens
ao traçar em três linhas da entrelinhas
de fia em fotos nos acabam por fazer
para ser melhor do que realmente somos
no caso dos homens
existem muitos símbolos os homens tentam
parecer sempre mais altos que no caso é
impossível mas tendo sempre por ser mais
altos mais confiantes e sobretudo ter um
maior conforto financeiro do que é o que
aparentemente têm as mulheres são muito
mais cinco dias em que passaram muitas
mulheres não estamos aqui confessar os
sons são muito mais simples nesta é essa
estratégia não querem exemplo a
resolução sem prometer mais altas e mais
novas e mais magras são sobretudo essa
secretaria é as características que elas
costumam alterar online só estas
personagens que conhecer no novo mundo
nos encontros digitais que eu vou falar
do piloto potter é um conceito que todos
os governantes de todos e todas as
pessoas que trabalham com ficção
compreendem mas que obviamente eu te
explicar porque são todos tirar um curso
em bom eu já queria que o meu
vou mostrar os nossos pais que isso
valeu a pena explicar os em três ou
quatro segundos o que é um piloto top
essencialmente e responder às questões
porque quando é onde com um guião e
através de uma ligação lógica entre
todas as partes da história ou seja
vocês chegarem aqui hoje tentarem trazer
a vitória porque será uma foto oficial e
sim práticas do brincar é essencialmente
do vosso quatro dias de hoje seria é
cruzarem o caso até aqui e fazer essas
perguntas porque quando tentarem
estabelecer uma ligação à lógica e
coerente entre essas entre essas fases e
essencialmente que acontece no kindle
muitas vezes nós tentamos antecipar o
que vai acontecer ou seja perdemos
aquela pessoa tem por exemplo há o curso
de direito e portanto vamos tentar
aprender a pressões diretas só para
ensinar aquela pessoa
sabemos que aquela pessoa foi é por isso
portanto vamos tentar procurar e no tipo
de melhor restaurante
é que não fomos para tentar impulsionar
essa pessoa e essencialmente assim que
tem funcionado hipóteses nessas nas
redes sociais encontro
sim mas dentro de uma estratégia e torna
o quadro previsível mas é off line faz
parte também da ficção o a idéia de
contar este ambiente eo tinga está em
contraste um ambiente muito específico é
o sociólogo é vincular o filme não sei
se alguns de vocês conhecem é frio é a
maior parte das interações sociais em
1959 como um pouco de teatro ou seja é
as pessoas em 11 é em relação às outras
conforme se tivessem um pouco de teatro
e uma parte dos jogadores que consigam
atender
use esta premissa é que estamos sempre
um palco constante de nossa atuação está
a ser observada uma força de nossos
personagens e construções da nossa da
nossa própria ficção
portanto hoje em dia o quanto a isto e
um ambiente muito nesta nesta ideia de
que somos todos os personagens
o contexto é muito específico como
sempre razão
existe um efeito de latência apesar de o
kinder tentarem glória 1 em gato real
por assim dizer
há uma certa tendência entre as portas a
outra pessoa entrou feedback que é
produzido na nossa comunicação e isso
permitiu que nós alteremos expectativas
da pessoa é que estamos a falar
como disse anteriormente é possível nós
mas não é tão pouco declarada é que a
pessoa acaba por se apaixonar por nós ou
por hora
nós fomos mais interessantes os motivos
que existem se foi pelo tse um contexto
específico é um ambiente específico em
relação ao gênero e temos aqui já ficar
o tempo todo novo é não entender muito
mais quando fazemos ficção é e sobretudo
quando se vê nos filmes podemos ter
presenças comédias românticas podemos
ter presente que representa os filmes de
ficção científica e não ter clássicos a
produzir por subgênero das pessoas com
quem estamos a falar com sua avaliação
quando fazendo delas e temos uma etapa
foi aqui que entra o conceito há uma
fila e temos uma função muito
muito muito focada em pessoas que são
mais semelhantes ao nosso gênero
hoje se eu for um filme saifi por uma
pessoa que é um filme saifi vou tentar
aprender a escrever
consoante as regras da cef neste caso eu
trouxe aqui um gráfico para essa rotina
muito interessante
a maior parte das pessoas procura
algumas características muito
semelhantes nas duas outras pessoas
online só precisa porque só passar aqui
um dado é 37% das pessoas a fim de ser
algo online numa rede social encontro
quando não é portanto mantendo atenção
as estatísticas aí e vão percebendo que
volta e meia vai ver uma pessoa que ela
não é exatamente aquilo que diz ser
essencialmente as pessoas querem pessoas
têm os mesmos hábitos de consumo de
álcool que ela só seja sejam
consumidores a não fumar é ok não fumem
que acreditem no mesmo estado civil que
elas e que não ter o mesmo número de
crianças é que se trata portanto a idéia
de que os opostos se atraem cada vez
mais com o advento das redes sociais
encontro e e é sobre isso que eu quero
fora que nessa parte final quando
terminamos um filme é a parte mais
difícil é chegar à mesma conclusão ea
resolução neste caso da redonda também
no facto de nós termos um herói que saiu
vencedor o vilão sai professor ou mesmo
um vilão que saiu vencedor
no caso do twitter anon em 36 possíveis
ou nos encontramos como pessoa e como
vamos tratar com ela o movimento poderá
apostar na mesma ou então teremos que
mudar para outra plataforma
sei lá nós vamos mandar a gente aquela
pessoa ou passamos é tentar entrar não
foi sua outra pessoa entra no país por
outras pessoas ou mal não tentará
contratar através do facebook é um caso
estranho ou então as pessoas nunca mais
se encontrou depois do primeiro contacto
e acabam pura por não se resolver entre
elas essencialmente é que a tendência
hoje em dia o qual vários como perguntam
e atenção o qual aliás é um amigo em
dólar com este ano
fica que se vive nos estados unidos da
américa e um maluquinho com uma mala
dinheiro pra entregar o caso ao
responder esta questão de forma correta
produto à espera da minha mala de
dinheiro e e as portas pra mim hoje em
dia o pronto vamos ver um time mais
ligado a uma fila ia a remoção de
atração barra em 3 entre pessoas que são
é mais próxima do nosso intelecto
aumente e fisicamente e hoje em dia como
vimos aqui o quadro ele traz pessoas
procuram muito mais pessoas que são
excelentes elas e o meu conselho é que
agiram como a minha colega o brasil era
mais um pouco
a ficção e esquecemos que não deve ficar
só para os adventistas mesmo horário às
17 horas nas redes sociais enquanto como
já perceberam e passará a ir muito mais
louco adora estar a tentar sobretudo que
as operações sejam mais genuínas e
deixaram os personagens também para a
ficção se nós mais reais e mais simples
possível porque só assim é que
efetivamente vamos encontrar a pessoa
com quem realmente está obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]